[Music]
stephanie is with us in arlington
virginia hi stephanie welcome to the
ramsay show
hello
hi
hi um so i am a a first-time caller but
big fan of the show
i am calling to get some advice i'm a
first-time homebuyer and i went in
uh
the deep end for my first buy
i've been renting ever since i graduated
college
and i am at 28 officially as of june and
i
ended up going into a large investment
and i'm just kind of looking to get
advice in terms of liquidating my assets
and my savings
hoping to do this without any of my
parents help
but they are offering
and unfortunately crypto is not an
option which i had actually spent some
time learning and investing in and
thought that would be an option to sell
my crypto but it sounds like freddie mac
and and such have not made legislation
that allows me to to use that but um
i i ended up selling all my employees
stock purchase
my employee stock
which got me about half of the down
payment from my home
um which is only 10
um
of the
actual loan
and the other half i'm looking at
um my 401k
and the first thing i found when i
looked up um in terms of getting a 401k
loan uh your show popped up in terms of
not getting ever getting a 401k loan um
i am able to take about 60k in cash or
the limit of 50k and a loan but i was
curious to just get your opinion in
terms of um the remaining
50k that i would like to liquidate
um
what would you suggest
knowing that i have um the 401k
and i'm happy to answer anything i got a
little bit lost in the process so you're
buying a home
you want to buy a home
you have your contract for the home
contract head i did all the home
inspection and now it's just in terms of
uh and you have you have 10 down from
the sale of employee stock
um yeah so in terms of the um
the mortgage
so
it was i'll just tell you the numbers it
was um 760 is what we closed on um and
you've already closed on it
oh it's not closed sorry that's not the
right question okay contracted for so
just stop just second i don't want to
hear all that that the bottom line is
you have 10 of your down payment you
have not closed yet in the bank from the
sale of employee stock correct
yes or no yes or no i need
no i am still working on getting that 10
percent i want to get 100 kit
okay so how much do you have from the
sale of the employee stock
employee stuck on a 55k 55k all right
and so you could do a fannie mae loan
with five percent down with that on a
15-year fixed what is your house what is
your
income my income is about 1 30.
okay all right so you can probably pull
this off
um
you have no other savings at all other
than 401k and you said you own some
crypto
yeah and i put down the uh 14.5 initial
um with just the cash that i had and
that was it
so you taught your earnest money check
what was that well you put down 14 500
as earnest money on the contract yes
yes all right so 55 and you have no
other money you have zero emergency fund
um i i do have another
td ameritrade stock uh that i could
sell or get
what does that work pre-cash what's that
i could i could pull out 23. it's 55
total but it is i could only access 23
without the double uh it's a roth r ira
so i would get double tax though
we don't cash out roth iras and we don't
cash out 401 k so we don't borrow on
401k
so why is it why is it you're not
cashing out your crypto
um it sounds like in terms of sourcing
um and trusting where that cash comes
from banks are not recognizing it in
terms of a down payment
no but if you sell your crypto and you
don't have the cash sell the crypto
what's it worth
um i have about 30k and krypto
today
um
i i believe there was an issue with with
that it needs to be on the books for
about two months
uh not no
you you don't have you have enough down
payment to close on the deal now
you just don't have enough that you want
you can you can do a 95
conventional fannie mae loan you have
five percent down
so you can do that but you're wanting to
put 10 down and we're trying to help you
get there plus you don't you have no
money that you can get to except
retirement accounts and you're gonna get
penalty you're gonna get your butt
penalized off okay you're too broke
you're too broke to buy this house way
too broke to buy this house but you've
already contracted for it you shouldn't
have bought it
because you've got all your money stuck
you gotta cause you don't have any money
you have no money you're broke
i mean all your money's tied up in
retirement accounts and other things so
anyway the
the deal is that um
uh uh
yeah i want you to have an emergency
fund in place a rainy day fund and i
don't want you
i i don't care but i'm saying what i
would advise you to do
because if i were in your shoes and woke
up you need to close on this deal you
put down earnest money you made a
promise you've made a pledge called a
contract to buy this house and so yeah
you need to cash out your crypto today
to be able to follow through on this and
and whatever and you need to have twenty
thousand dollars cash in the bank after
you close on this house
do not close on this house and put every
dime you have into it because as soon as
you move in crap's gonna fall in
you're gonna need a new roof and you're
asking for trouble you're asking for
trouble being broke and buying a house
and so uh it's not a blessing to buy a
house when you're broke you just got the
28 year old fever i gotta have a house
especially a three-quarter of a million
dollar house and you do make 130 grand
which feels like a lot but you bought a
three-quarter of a million dollar house
with no
money yeah so broke your 401k and your
roth ira does not count because you
cannot get to that without penalties and
taxes you start cashing this stuff out
you're going to get hit with a 10
penalty plus your tax rate so you're
going to get hit with 40 percent dave i
want to borrow money at 40 interest to
buy this house
i would say no don't do that that
doesn't sound wise
and that is exactly what you sure
wouldn't take out a mortgage for 40 yeah
right interest
geez nuts and but i'm keeping my
freaking crypto and i know it's cool
yeah to sit at some cool hipster bar and
be like i got crypto you're broke
sell it
typical crypto investor put 30 000 cash
under your pillow for crying out loud
yeah yeah you need you need to put 20
000 bucks in the bank and put the other
10 000 the crypto with the 55 and put a
65 000 down payment on this house and
close on it yeah and for god's sakes put
it on a 15-year fixed and then get a
six-month emergency fund then work on
your 20 000 and start building up your
emergency fund there
so yeah
i don't even
it's tough man
it's um
it's just what we talked about in
another segment it's just you get this
picture in your head and you start
getting this fever and all of a sudden
i'm gonna do this and move that and sell
that and hold on to this and all these
competing pictures when you collide when
you force a deal yeah you always do a
bad deal man and you're forcing this one
for sure
but yeah you had a whole bunch of stuff
going on you need to clean up here
anyway so that's good you have the stock
options you need the employee stock
options you need to clean up you need to
clean up the crypto and you need to get
over and now you can sit down build your
emergency fund start doing your uh
investing steadily into building some
wealth in your 401k once your emergency
fund's in place
and quit screwing around with the rest
of this stuff yeah i still mess with it
you just it's not going to get you where
you want to go yeah but hey thank you
for the call and i hope that helps you